This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. They are on our TVs, on our phones, and on highway billboards. Flourless, airbrushed images of beautiful people living beautiful lives. Their complexions glow, their wealth seems effortless, and their children are always smiling. All of us are surrounded by these pictures of perfection, pictures that contrast all too starkly, with our own complicated messy lives.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。它们出现在我们的电视上、手机上以及高速公路的巨型广告牌上。那些精修的、空气刷喷涂的完美画像，展现着过着完美生活的美丽人们。他们的气色红润，财富似乎唾手可得，他们的孩子也总是面带微笑。我们所有人都被这些完美的照片所包围，这些照片与我们自己复杂而凌乱的生活形成了过于鲜明的对比。
Social media platforms exacerbate this, friends post pictures of their idyllic vacations, colleagues announce promotions, a lot of people use the hashtag, Blessed. Meanwhile, divorces, demotions, and despair are the challenges of making ends meet. These show up rarely or not at all. What is the effect of the sharp contrast between the worlds we are shown and the worlds we
社交媒体平台加剧了这种现象，朋友们发布他们田园诗般假期的照片，同事们宣布升职，许多人使用“幸福”这个标签。与此同时，离婚、降职和绝望才是维持生计所要面对的挑战。这些情况很少出现，或者根本不出现。我们被展示的世界与我们
are cells inhabit? We may remind ourselves that what we are seeing has been airbrushed and filtered, but the contrast still borrows into our unconscious minds. Some researchers have argued that this contrast produces in us nagging feelings of inferiority, shame and resentment. It causes us to feel we never have enough and to reach endlessly for the next ring, the next achievement, the next milestone. The costs of chasing perfection, this week on Hidden Brain. F's Cart Fitzgerald's masterpiece, The Great Gatsby, describes the story of a man who desperately tried to climb the social ladder.
细胞所栖息的世界之间，这种强烈的对比会产生什么影响？我们可能会提醒自己，我们所看到的一切都经过了精修和滤镜处理，但这种对比仍然会潜入我们的潜意识中挥之不去。一些研究人员认为，这种对比会在我们心中产生挥之不去的自卑感、羞耻感和怨恨感。它让我们觉得自己永远不够好，并促使我们不断地去追求下一个目标、下一次成就、下一个里程碑。追求完美的代价，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。菲茨杰拉德的杰作《了不起的盖茨比》描述了一个拼命往上爬的男人的故事。
The final lines of the novel are amongst the most famous in literature. They read, Gatsby believed in the green light, the orgyastic future that year by year receipts before us. It eluded us then, but that's no matter. Tomorrow we will run faster, stretch out our arms farther, and one fine morning. So we beat on, boats against the current, born back ceaselessly, into the past. At the London School of Economics, psychologists Thomas Karin studies how many of us are modern versions of J. Gatsby.
这部小说的最后几句是文学史上最著名的话语之一。它们写道：盖茨比相信那盏绿灯，那年复一年在我们面前倒退的狂欢般的未来。它当年曾躲开我们，但这没关系——明天我们将跑得更快，把手臂伸得更远……于是一个迎风逆水的小舟，不停地被退回过去。在伦敦政治经济学院，心理学家托马斯·卡林研究了我们当中有多少人是J·盖茨比的现代版。
He explores the psychological consequences of living in a culture that is obsessed with appearance and achievement. Thomas Karin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Thomas, you grew up in a working-class family in a small town in England and as a teenager you were acutely aware of the social status of two friends Kevin and Ian and the contrast with your own family's means. Can you paint me a picture of what that was like? Yeah so my upbringing was one of love and support but also material like we didn't have a great deal of money and one of my earliest memories of that is going to school with the wrong backpack or the wrong pencil case,
他探讨了生活在痴迷于外表和成就的文化中所带来的心理后果。托马斯·卡林，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。托马斯，你在英国一个小镇的工人阶级家庭长大，作为一名青少年，你对两个朋友凯文和伊安的社会地位有着敏锐的意识，并且觉得这与你自己的家庭条件形成了鲜明的对比。你能给我描绘一下当时的情景吗？是的，我的成长环境充满了爱和支持，但在物质上，你知道的，我们没有太多的钱，我最早的记忆之一就是背着错误的双书包去学校，或者带着错误的铅笔盒，
the wrong brand of sneakers. I didn't have gadgets like a Game Boy or a PlayStation phones were just coming in there and didn't have one of those either and when I compared myself with these two characters Kevin and Ian, who had all of those things, and were able to express their personalities and their identities with these material goods, you kind of feel like even though this is all stupid stuff, right, just stuff, but it really matters to a kid, especially if you don't have it. So as I grew older and things like cars started to come into the picture, this kind of shame really started to get really into my bones and that was huge actually. Cars was a massive part of this because cars are the
错误的运动鞋品牌。我没有像 Game Boy 或 PlayStation 那样的电子设备，手机当时刚开始流行，我也没有那种东西。当我把自己和凯文、伊安这两个拥有所有这些东西、并且能够用这些物质商品表达他们的个性和身份的角色进行比较时，你就会觉得，尽管这些都是愚蠢的东西，对吧，只是一些东西，但对于一个孩子来说，这真的很重要，特别是当你没有这些东西的时候。所以随着我长大，汽车之类的东西开始进入我的视野，这种羞耻感真的开始深入我的骨髓，这实际上是巨大的。汽车是其中的一大部分，因为汽车是
kind of the ultimate status in right. You just look at how they advertised. All my friends were bought these really super sleek cars with modifications and all the rest of it and I was like really crushing for me That was really embarrassing not to be able to have one too. I didn't have the freedom that they had. I couldn't go anywhere I just tagged along really in the back seat tonight I think suppose this is where I first learned about shame what it meant to feel ashamed and embarrassed about where I am in life and what I have And I sort of learned that you kind of got to buy your way out of that shame in this world, and that became, I guess, an early motivation. I understand that at one point Kevin and Ian asked you what car you were going to be
终极身份的象征，对吧。你只要看看他们是怎么做广告的。我所有的朋友都买下了这些经过改装的超级流线型汽车以及其他所有东西，而我觉得这对我来说简直是个打击。买不起一辆车真的让我感到很尴尬。我没有他们那样的自由，我哪儿也去不了，我晚上真的只能坐在后座上蹭车。我想，也就是在这里，我第一次懂得了羞耻，懂得了对自己所处的境地和拥有的东西感到羞耻和尴尬意味着什么。我有点明白，在这个世界上，你必须通过花钱来摆脱这种羞耻感，我想，这成为了我早期的动力。据我了解，凯文和伊安曾一度问你打算买什么车，
buying Thomas, what did they ask you, what did you say? So they had these, what we call hot hatchbacks in the UK, you know, the really fast, exciting pieces of machinery I suppose. And everybody around the town would be asking, you know, what are you going to get? And you're going to get this one, you're going to get that one, you're going to get these plates, and what about these trims and these wheels? And you know, I used to love looking at car magazines and craving for a car of my own. And I would always say, you know, well,
托马斯，他们问了你什么，你是怎么回答的？所以他们拥有这些，我们在英国称之为高性能两厢车（hot hatchbacks）的东西，你知道的，就是那些速度极快、令人兴奋的机器我想。镇上的每个人都会问，你知道的，你要买哪辆？你打算买这辆吗，你要买那辆吗，你会选这些车牌吗，这些内饰和轮毂呢？你知道的，我以前很喜欢看汽车杂志，渴望拥有一辆自己的车。我总是说，你知道的，
I'm going to have this and I'm going to have that. When I get my car, it's going to have a silver trim and chrome wheels and all of these things that everybody else was talking about. I would say that one day my dad's gonna come back and he's gonna buy me a car or it's not gonna be long now, you know, and I kind of wished I hoped that that would happen, but of course unlike them, my family didn't have the means to be able to buy me these things and it wasn't my fault, there was nothing that I could have done to change those circumstances, but you feel it's some way that you're in Attacot, you're less than.
我要买这个，我要买那个。当我买到车的时候，它将拥有银色内饰、镀铬轮毂以及每个人都在谈论的所有这些东西。我会说，总有一天我爸爸会回来给我买辆车，或者不用等太久了，你知道的，我当时既希望又盼望着那种情况会发生，但当然，和他们不同的是，我的家庭没有能力给我买这些东西，这不是我的错，我本可以做任何事情来改变这些环境，但你在某种程度上会觉得你低人一等，你不如别人。
So later on in life, you were determined to get ahead and you became the first in your family to go to college. You had a fearsome work ethic. Tell me about it, Thomas. So I came through the education system actually a really unique time. In the UK, Tony Blair was the prime minister and he had a great education push at that time. This was the late 90s, early 90s and there was a lot of finance to go to university.
所以在后来的生活中，你决心出人头地，成为了家族中第一个上大学的人。你有着可怕的强烈的职业道德。跟我说说这个吧，托马斯。我经历教育系统其实是在一个非常独特的时期。在英国，托尼·布莱尔是首相，他在当时大力推动教育。那是90年代末，90年代初，当时有很多资金可以用来上大学。
So I took that up and I managed to scrape my way to a local teaching college to study sport with every intention of being a PE teacher that was going to be my ambition. And I guess you could say I was lucky really because at my time at that teaching college I happened to intersect with a professor who was on his way to more prestigious university and must have impressed him because he took me with him to do a PhD and that was when the things started to really get quite crazy because I remember instantly being inside this hyper competitive university environment being surrounded by people who were just way smarter than me, more aerodiot, way more put together, people
所以我抓住了这个机会，设法勉强考入了一所地方师范学院学习体育，满心希望能成为一名体育老师，这就是我的雄心。我想你可以说我很幸运，因为我在那所师范学院期间，碰巧遇到了一位正准备前往更负盛名的大学的教授，我一定给他留下了深刻的印象，因为他带我一起去攻读博士学位。也就是在那时，事情开始变得相当疯狂，因为我记得自己立刻置身于这个超级竞争的大学环境中，身边都是比我聪明得多、博学得多、更有头绪的人，大家
were pumping out publications, some of them were even getting grant money at. And in that environment, those early feelings of shame and inferiority that I kind of brought with me started to come back again in mega doses. And I think my response really looking back was to develop what can I really describe as an urgent need to lift myself above other people through an excessive form of striving. of other people through an excessive form of striving. Like, made sure I was the first in the office and the last to leave and made sure people saw that. You know, I'd regularly do 80 hour weeks and I'd let everybody know in the office
都在疯狂地发表文章，其中一些人甚至还拿到了科研经费。在那种环境中，我随身带来的那些早期的羞耻感和自卑感开始成倍地卷土重来。回想起来，我的反应实际上是发展出了我能真正描述为一种通过过度奋斗的形式把自己提升到其他人之上的迫切需求。通过过度奋斗的形式把自己提升到其他人之之上。比如，确保我是办公室里第一个到、最后一个走的人，并确保大家都能看到这一点。你知道的，我经常每周工作80个小时，而且我会让办公室里的每个人都知道
that I was doing that. I sent these kind of weird conspicuous emails to my academic supervisors in the early hours of the morning and sometimes last thing at night just to let them know that I'm working and I can remember one Christmas doing a thousand words on my thesis on Christmas day and at that time I felt really proud of it. You know these are incredibly unhealthy things to do but nevertheless I believed if I didn't do these things, there's no way I was going to succeed.
我在这样做。我会在清晨甚至有时在深夜给我的学术导师发送这些奇怪的、显眼的电子邮件，只是为了让他们知道我在工作。我记得有一次圣诞节，我在圣诞节当天写了一千字的论文，当时我对此感到非常自豪。你知道的，这些都是极其不健康的做法，但尽管如此，我相信如果我不这样做，我是绝对不可能成功的。
So you eventually achieved prominence in your field, you got a job at a top to your university and your new status lifted you into unfamiliar realms where you often felt out of place. You were once invited for example to give a high profile speech at a fancy resort where people had paid a lot of money to attend this event. Tell me what happened, Thomas. Yeah, so all that work did end up paying off and I was able to elevate myself through the academic ladder, I should say, into second tier and then elite institutions. And that's when I did a very important TED Talk, a resort in the US back in 2018.
所以你最终在你的领域取得了显赫的地位，你在一个顶尖大学找到了一份工作，你的新地位把你提升到了你不熟悉的领域，你在那里经常感到格格不入。例如，你曾经受邀在一个高级度假村发表备受瞩目的演讲，人们花了很多钱来参加这个活动。告诉我发生了什么，托马斯。是的，所有这些努力最终确实得到了回报，我得以通过学术阶梯提升自己，我应该说，先是进入二级机构，然后是精英机构。也就是在那时，我在2018年美国的一个度假村做了一场非常重要的TED演讲。
And I think going to that TED Talk was when I finally realized I'd sort of made something of myself here. But nevertheless, I really felt out of place at that conference. There's people that were paying thousands of pounds. They were from, you know, I taught you taught to them, they're from this mega firm or that mega firm or that big industry and it was kind of overwhelming a little bit. And they sort of just carried themselves with confidence and again, this kind of overwhelming a little bit and they sort of just carried themselves with confidence and again this kind of really picked my thoughts of inferiority. And now the weird thing was I was the one on the stage.
我想去参加那个TED演讲，才让我终于意识到我在这里算是小有成就了。然而，我在那个会议上确实感到了格格不入。有些人付了数千英镑。他们来自，你知道的，我跟他们交谈过，他们来自这个大公司或那个大公司或那个大产业，这有点让人不知所措。他们表现得非常自信，再次，这有点让人不知所措，他们表现得非常自信，而这再次深深地触动了我的自卑感。而奇怪的是，站在舞台上的人是我。
I was the one who they were there to see. I'm a bit of a perfectionist now. How many times have you heard that one? How did the talk itself go? Give me a sense of the preparation you put in and how the talk itself was delivered and how it was received. So the talk itself was extremely nerve-wracking,
我才是他们来看的人。我现在是个完美主义者。这句话你听过多少次了？那场演讲本身进展得怎么样？让我感受一下你付出的准备工作，演讲本身是怎样交付的，以及它是如何被接受的。所以演讲本身非常让人神经紧张，
but I'm not a natural speaker. It's not something that I ever thought I would do. And I've kind of just been thrust into in a profession that kind of requires you to be pretty good at speaking. So one of the things I do to combat the anxiety that's associated with that is to overthink things, over prepare, because in my mind that's the most failsafe way to make sure things don't go wrong. It's so important that you don't show an ounce of weakness or vulnerability, because in that moment, things can cascade,
但我不是一个天生的演讲者。这不是我想过要做的事情。我只是被推入了一个需要你擅长演讲的职业中。因此，为了克服与之相关的焦虑，我所做的事情之一就是过度思考、过度准备，因为在我看来，这是确保事情不出差错的最万无一失的方法。展现出一丝一毫的软弱或脆弱是极其危险的，因为在那一刻，事情可能会失控、
they can spiral, and when it's so public, that's when you feel like your deficiencies are short, coming, it's a being exposed. And in the end, I was able to recite a 15 minute talk word for word without any mistakes, which was incredibly important for me, but at the same time, it wasn't the most charismatic of talks, it wasn't the most inspirational, but I did
可能会陷入恶性循环，而当这一切如此公开时，就会让你觉得自己的缺陷和短处正在暴露无遗。最后，我能够一字不差地背诵完一篇15分钟的演讲，没有任何错误，这对我来说极其重要，但与此同时，它并不是最具有个人魅力的演讲，也不是最具有启发性的演讲，但我做到了，
it, and people were very polite and they applauded, and I'm sure they appreciated it, but at the same time, you could tell that it wasn't quite the show-stopping talk that perhaps other people at the conference had been able to deliver. You do think about that. So in the aftermath of the talk, when you sort of looked back on it, did you remember sort of the polite applause? What portion of it did you end up ruminating on? I was very aware that it wasn't a rouser speech, the others are delivered.
人们非常有礼貌，他们鼓了掌，我相信他们也很感激，但与此同时，你能看出这并不是其他会议演讲者所能发表的那种能够震惊全场的演讲。你确实会去想这些。所以在演讲结束后，当你回顾它时，你是否还记得那些礼貌的掌声？你最终反刍的是哪一部分？我非常清楚这不是别人发表的那种激昂人心的演讲。
And so I wondered, did it look still to you? Was it very one-dimensional or monotonic? Was I able to convey the ideas in a way that changed people or in some way made them think differently about the topic? These were the goals I had going in, but I wasn't sure in those moments where I'd actually achieved them. So your anxieties about your shortcomings read something of a peak after a romantic relationship ended, Thomas, tell me about that period in your life and what happened? It was a very messy breakup that happened in a
所以我想知道，在你看来它还是显得很呆板吗？它是非常单一维度的还是单调的？我是否能够以一种能够改变人们的方式传达这些思想，或者以某种方式让他们对这个话题有不同的思考？这些是我一开始的目标，但在那些时刻，我并不确定自己是否真正达到了这些目标。所以，在一段浪漫关系结束之后，你对自身缺陷的焦虑达到了一种顶峰，托马斯，跟我说说你生命中的那段时期以及发生了什么？那是一次非常糟糕的分手，发生在一场
really exposing way and it was something that made me feel very humiliating, humiliating, excuse me. I worried about how it would look to other people, like Chastai as myself about that breakup and what it said about me and that was turning itself into all sorts of negative beliefs about myself. Why can't you snap out of it? Why can't you just get through this? So I felt a lot of self-loving, a lot of shame, a lot of grief, and I went into a really dark place in those moments and what I needed to do more than anything else was to just stop and deal with the emotional plunge that I was experiencing. But my personality wouldn't let me do that. But my personality wouldn't let me do that. And if anything, I was trying to push myself even harder
非常暴露的方式中，这让我感到非常屈辱，非常屈辱，对不起。我担心在别人眼里会是什么样子，比如我如何责备自己那次分手以及它说明了什么关于我的问题，这演变成了关于我自己的各种消极信念。你为什么就不能从这种情绪中走出来？你为什么就不能度过这个坎？所以我感到了很多自我谴责、很多羞耻、很多悲伤，在那几个时刻我陷入了一个非常黑暗的地方，我最需要做的事情其实就是停下来，处理我正在经历的情感低谷。但我的性格不允许我这样做。但我的性格不允许我这样做。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是我试图更加努力地推自己，
to overcompensate for the things that were now starting to go wrong as a function of the breakup and how it impacted on my emotional well-being. Some months later, Thomas was working in his office when he started to see flashes. He had no idea what was going on. And the flashes started to get bright, to the stage obscure. What I could see, I could concentrate on the thing I was reading. I had trouble breathing, my throat became really tight and so I tried to get some water but that was no use so run out into the open road and try to kind of suck the fresh air but
去过度补偿那些由于分手以及它如何影响我的情绪健康而开始出错的事情。几个月后，托马斯正在办公室工作，突然开始看到眼前闪光。他不知道发生了什么事。闪光开始变得刺眼，甚至到了遮蔽视线的地步。我能看到的东西，我无法集中精力阅读我正在阅读的东西。我呼吸困难，喉咙变得非常紧，所以我试图喝点水，但这无济于事，所以我跑到空旷的路上，试图呼吸新鲜空气，但
none of it was really working and it just started to take over and this panic was starting to feed the panic and then you worry what on earth is going on and my dying is this it. And then after a few minutes of complete meltdown, I would say my body just started to come back to me. I was able to regulate my breathing, my heart rate came down and I was almost to suppose back in the world again. And at the time, I didn't know what Earth that was and I'm sure many of you listening
这些都没有真正起作用，这种恐慌开始接管一切，这种恐慌开始助长更多的恐慌，然后你开始担心这到底是怎么回事，我是不是要死了。然后在大约几分钟的彻底崩溃之后，我想我的身体开始恢复过来。我能够调节我的呼吸，我的心率降下来了，我想我差不多又回到了这个世界上。当时，我不知道那到底是什么鬼东西，我相信许多在听节目的朋友
can resonate, but that was a panic attack that comes from the bursting of the dam of this kind of suppressed anxiety that we're just holding back. And that panic attack was really the first of many, but it was an eye-opener for me and showed me that the way that I was you know, approaching life, trying to achieve, trying to prove to everybody that I was good enough was actually coming at a great expense of mental health. When we come back, Thomas explores the root of his self-doubt and self-castigation and discovers that his affliction is all too common in our modern world.
都能感同身受，但那是由于我们一直压抑的焦虑之坝决堤而引发的恐慌发作。那次恐慌发作确实是多次发作中的第一次，但它对我来说是一个启示，向我表明我对待生活的方式——试图取得成就，试图向所有人证明我足够优秀——实际上是以牺牲精神健康为巨大代价换来的。稍后回来，托马斯将探讨他自我怀疑和自我谴责的根源，并发现他的这种痛苦在我们的现代世界中其实非常普遍。
You'll listen to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. A few years ago, an electronic trading platform ran an ad that was simultaneously funny, sad, and revealing. A young man sits on an airplane. The kid in the seat behind him kicks his tray table into the young man's backrest over and over again. Glimpsing a better world in the front of the aircraft, the young man makes his way to an open curtain. In the first class cabin, beautiful people lounge on spacious sofas. They drink champagne in long stem glasses.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔。几年前，一家电子交易平台投放了一则广告，这则广告既搞笑、悲伤又极具启示性。一个年轻男子坐在飞机上。他身后的孩子不断用脚踢他的小桌板，撞击年轻男子的靠背。年轻男子瞥见飞机前舱有一个更好的世界，便朝着一道敞开的幕帘走去。在头等舱里，美丽的人们斜靠在宽敞的沙发上。他们用长柄酒杯喝着香槟。
But just as the young man thinks he's going to be invited into the special world, the open curtain is slam-shot. The tagline reads, first class is there to remind you, you're not in first class. Psychologist Thomas Karin knows all about that curtain. He has seen it in his own life, but also in the lives of his students. Thomas, your students at the London School of Economics are smart and hardworking, but many of them come to you in a state of distress. You talk
但就在年轻男子以为自己会被邀请进入这个特殊世界时，敞开的幕帘被“砰”地一声关上了。广告标语写道：头等舱的存在是为了提醒你，你并不在头等舱。心理学家托马斯·卡林对那道幕帘了如指掌。他在自己的生活中见过它，也在学生的生活中见过。托马斯，你在伦敦政治经济学院的学生聪明又努力，但他们中的许多人在向你求助时都处于痛苦的状态。你谈到了
about one student whom you call John, who exemplified this phenomenon. What was John's story? What I see in young people and students that come through the door is a lot of tension that's bound up in a intense need to excel. And all of my students at some level feel this, but there was definitely a vivid case in John who I think was a very extreme case of that intense desire and need to do things perfectly, excellently to excel at all times. He would constantly come to me in meetings telling me that his grades weren't good enough, even though they were really high, that they weren't good enough, that he didn't feel like he was succeeding in the measure that he expected
一个你称之为约翰的学生，他就是这种现象的典范。约翰的故事是怎样的？我在前来求助的年轻人和学生身上看到的是，大量紧张情绪被捆绑在了一种对卓越的强烈需求上。我所有的学生在某种程度上都感受到了这一点，但约翰绝对是一个生动的例子，我认为他是那种强烈渴望和需要把事情做到完美、卓越、在任何时候都追求卓越的极端案例。他会不断地来找我开会，告诉我说他的成绩不够好，尽管他们的成绩其实已经非常高了，但他们觉得不够好，觉得自己在预期中并没有达到
of himself. And the matter really how I tried to reconcile those things and tell him that what he's doing is exceptional, he always recasted those successes that abject failures and how he'd let himself and other people down. And this was so sad because John really found it difficult to see his successes in any other way. And his justification really, at all times, very simple, how could he be a success when he was trying so much harder than other people just to get the same outcomes? Well, that's the thing with being at LSE, everyone's exceptional. And not being able to derive any lasting satisfaction from success is really a kind of signature of the way my students interpret their experience at university.
自己对自己的期望。无论我如何试图调和这些事情，告诉他他所做的一切是多么出色，他总是把那些成功重新定义为彻头彻尾的失败，认为自己辜负了自己和其他人。这太令人悲伤了，因为约翰真的很难用任何其他方式来看待自己的成功。他的理由其实一直非常简单：当他比其他人付出多得多的努力却只得到相同的成果时，他怎么能算是一个成功者呢？这就是身处LSE的问题所在，每个人都极其优秀。无法从成功中获得任何持久的满足感，这确实可以说是我的学生们解释他们在大学经历时的标志性特征。
They find it difficult to deal with setbacks. And I think sometimes we misunderstand this as being fragile or young people lacking resilience, but really it's just excessive self-imposed pressures and a deep and profound fear of failure. So Thomas, you eventually came to recognise that both you and students like John were suffering from the same affliction. What was your insight?
他们觉得很难应对挫折。我想有时我们误解这是因为他们脆弱或年轻人缺乏韧性，但实际上这只是过度的自我施加的压力以及对失败的深深恐惧。所以托马斯，你最终认识到，你和像约翰这样的学生都在遭受同一种痛苦。你的见解是什么？
So it became evident to me that myself, my students and many, many people around me were struggling with something called perfectionism and need and desire to do things perfectly and nothing but perfectly that comes from a sense of lack, a sense of inferiority, a sense of deficiency, a sense that I'm not perfect and in order to gain approval and validation in this world that I'm worth something, that I matter, that I need to be perfect. So you've conducted a study that has tracked levels of perfectionism over time. What do you find? So we've found recently that perfectionism is increasing among more recent generations of young people.
因此，我逐渐清楚地认识到，我自己、我的学生以及我周围许许多多的人都在与一种叫做完美主义的东西作斗争——那种把事情做到完美、除完美之外别无所求的需求和渴望，这种渴望源于一种匮乏感、自卑感、缺陷感，源于一种“我不够完美，为了在这个世界上获得认可和肯定，证明自己有价值、有意义，我必须追求完美”的感觉。所以你进行了一项研究，追踪了不同时期的完美主义水平。你发现了什么？所以我们最近发现，在更年轻的年轻一代中，完美主义正在增加。
This was a study we did back now in 2016-2017, essentially looking at college-dune data, have perfectionism. So we have about 30 years worth of perfectionism data, looking at various indicators of perfectionism. And we found when we ran the numbers that perfectionism was increasing, and increasing really rapidly, it's up about 40% since 1989 and that's concerning because it's associated most strongly with negative mental health outcomes like depression, anxiety, self-harm and this hard data is telling us something significant and something that we need to be paying attention to. So, perfectionism is really fascinating because unlike many other flaws, many people celebrate the straight. You call perfectionism our favorite flaw.
这是我们在2016年至2017年做的一项研究，主要是查看大学生关于完美主义的数据。我们拥有大约30年的完美主义数据，观察了完美主义的各种指标。当我们对数据进行分析时，我们发现完美主义一直在增加，而且增长速度非常快，自1989年以来上升了大约40%，这令人担忧，因为它与抑郁、焦虑、自残等消极心理健康结果最密切相关，而这些确凿的数据告诉了我们一些重要的事情，也是我们需要关注的事情。所以，完美主义真的很迷人，因为与许多其他缺陷不同，许多人赞美这种特质。你称完美主义为我们最喜欢的缺陷。
What do you mean by that? Perfectionism is something that I think in modern society is lionized, celebrated. We know it carries self-sacrificial patterns of behaviour, it makes us feel a bit miserable but nevertheless, we also think that perfectionism is what carries us forward and makes us successful. A necessary evil, so to speak, if we want to get ahead, we might need a bit of perfectionism. And of course, this has become something of a joke as well, Thomas, in many job interviews when Canada to ask to name a flaw, many of them will say, I'm a perfectionist.
你这话是什么意思？完美主义是我认为在现代社会中被神化、被赞美的特质。我们知道它带有自我牺牲的行为模式，它让我们感到有点痛苦，但尽管如此，我们也认为完美主义正是推动我们前进并让我们取得成功的动力。可以说是一种“必要的恶”，如果我们想要出人头地，我们可能需要一点完美主义。当然，这也成了一个笑话，托马斯，在许多求职面试中，当候选人被要求说出一个缺点时，许多人会说：“我是个完美主义者。”
Yeah, that's exactly right. And recruiters, time after time, tell us that that's the most overused cliche in job interviews. And I think it says something about what we consider to be socially desirable weaknesses, that if somehow we can communicate that we're willing to sacrifice ourselves in some way and push ourselves beyond comfort, that that is something that else sees positive, something that they really want on their team or in their organization. So that speaks really to the ubiquity of perfectionism at the moment. I want to spend a moment talking about what perfectionism is and what it's not,
是的，完全正确。招聘人员一次又一次地告诉我们，这是求职面试中最被过度使用的陈词滥调。我认为这说明了我们所认为的社会期望的弱点是什么：如果某种程度上我们可以传达出我们愿意在某种程度上牺牲自己并把自己推向舒适区之外的意愿，这就被视为积极的事情，是他们真正希望团队或组织中拥有的人。所以这确实说明了目前完美主义的无处不在。我想花点时间讨论一下什么是完美主义以及什么不是完美主义，
because I think many of us might use the same word but mean different things by it. Many people might say perfectionism is about setting high standards and working hard to meet them, but that's very different, I think, from your definition. You say perfectionism is less about pursuing success and more about avoiding failure. One of its hallmarks is something you'll call a deficit orientation. What do you mean by this term? So a lot of people associate perfectionism with really high standards. That's true.
因为我认为我们很多人可能会使用同一个词，但意思却不尽相同。许多人可能会说，完美主义就是设定高标准并努力去实现它们，但我认为这与你的定义大不相同。你说完美主义与其说是追求成功，不如说是逃避失败。它的标志之一就是你所说的“缺陷导向”。你这个词是什么意思？所以很多人把完美主义与极高的标准联系在一起。这确实是真的。
But actually perfectionism is far, far deeper than what we see on the surface because what's really matters is where it's coming from and where those excessive amounts of striving and high standards and go getting attitudes that you see on the surface are coming from and the perfectionist people is a place of lack as a sense that I'm not good enough, that I'm not perfect enough and I need to prove to other people all the time that I'm worth something, that I matter in this world and the way that I do that is through being perfect because of course if I'm perfect I'll get their validation and
但实际上，完美主义远比我们在表面上看到的要深刻得多，因为真正重要的是它的根源，以及你在表面上看到的那些过度的奋斗、高标准和进取心的态度究竟来自哪里。对于完美主义者来说，这种态度源于一种匮乏感，源于一种“我不够好”、“我不够完美”的感觉，源于一种我需要向其他人不断证明自己有价值、在这个世界上有意义的感觉，而我做到这一点的方式就是通过追求完美，因为当然，如果我完美了，我就会得到他们的认可，
that will make me feel better. That will soothe those shame-based fears of not being good enough. So two people could work very hard. They can both have high standards. They can both care about getting things right. You know, one person might just be conscientious while the other person is a perfectionist. And the distinction you're drawing is really what's driving them on the inside.
这会让我感觉更好。这会抚平那些基于羞耻感的、觉得自己不够好的恐惧。所以两个人可以非常努力地工作。他们都可以有很高的标准。他们都可以关心把事情做好。你知道，一个人可能只是认真负责，而另一个人则是完美主义者。而你划清的界限实际上是驱动他们内心深处的东西。
Are you chasing success or are you fleeing failure? But there are also some external markers to perfectionism and with perfectionists and counter adversity, you found the often respond with shame and with guilt. Can you explain what that means Thomas? So what we see in the labs is exactly what I experienced when I encountered that breakup in my own life. When you put perfectionistic people in stressful situations, perfectionism will aggravate the stress.
你是在追逐成功，还是在逃避失败？但完美主义也有一些外部标志，当完美主义者遭遇逆境时，你发现他们通常会以羞耻和内疚来回应。你能解释一下这意味着什么吗，托马斯？所以我们在实验室里看到的情况，正是我在自己的生活中遭遇那次分手时所经历的。当你把完美主义者置于压力情境中时，完美主义会加剧这种压力。
So every time you go into the lab, you tell perfectionistic people to do stressful things, like maybe give a public talk or complete a competitive task against other people. And in the end you say you didn't do very well or you failed. What you'll see is perfectionistic people respond with intense amounts of self-conscious emotion, lots of shame, lots of guilt about having slipped up in some way, particularly if that slip up is public.
所以每次你走进实验室，你让完美主义者做一些有压力的事情，比如做一次公众演讲，或者与其他人进行一场竞争性的任务。最后你告诉他们你做得不是很好或者你失败了。你会看到的是，完美主义者会以强烈的情绪表现来回应，会有大量的羞耻感，会有大量因为在某些方面失误而产生的内疚感，特别是如果这种失误是公开的话。
It validates in them a sense that if that slip up is public, it validates in them a sense that that fear that they're not good enough. Whereas people who score lower on the perfectionism scales, well yes of course these things do have an impact on their emotional state, but it's a far less profound impact and they're able to bounce back quite quickly. profound impact and they're able to bounce back quite quickly. You told me that after that talk that you gave you engage in a lot of brooding and rumination about how the talk went and you're worried that it had not landed properly or what could have gone better But you're also seeing this in the data that perfectionists engage in a lot of brooding and rumination and revisiting things over and over again.
这证实了他们内心的一种感觉，即如果这种失误是公开的，就会验证他们那种“自己不够好”的恐惧。而那些在完美主义量表上得分较低的人，虽然这些事情确实会对他们的情绪状态产生影响，但这种影响要深远得多，而且他们能够相当快地恢复过来。深远的影响，而且他们能够相当快地恢复过来。你告诉我，在你做完那次演讲之后，你进行了大量的反思和反刍，思考演讲进展得如何，你担心它没有产生预期的效果，或者有什么地方可以做得更好。但你也在数据中看到，完美主义者会进行大量的反思和反刍，并一遍又一遍地回想事情。
Perfection stick people, people who are higher in the perfectionism spectrum, what you tend to see is they also score higher on what we would call self sabotaging, fault patterns. So things like you mentioned there, worry, rumination, they're really hyper-vigilant about where they sit relative to others, how they're performing relative to others. They find it very difficult to exist in the moment or be mindful or appreciate successes. And so perfectionists, people really find it difficult to thrive or flourish because they're constantly worried about what's going to go wrong or how other people are doing. Now perfectionists take people off and work very hard,
完美主义倾向较强的人，即在完美主义光谱上得分更高的人，你往往会发现他们在我们所谓的“自我破坏性思维模式”上的得分也更高。所以就像你刚才提到的那些事情，担忧、反刍，他们对自己在他人眼中的地位、自己相对于他人的表现处于什么位置保持着高度的警惕。他们发现自己很难存在于当下、保持正念或欣赏成功。因此，完美主义者真的很难繁荣或蓬勃发展，因为他们总是担心什么地方会出问题，或者别人做得怎么样。现在，完美主义者通常工作非常努力，
but one of the really curious insights that you and others have had is that they often don't pay attention to working smartly. They are sometimes indifferent to what's called diminishing productivity returns. What does this mean Thomas? Yeah, so that's a really curious finding actually in the perfectionism literature. We know perfectionists work really hard and they push themselves well beyond comfort into a zone of declining and diminishing returns for every little bit of effort that they put in. Failure is very common among infectious people because the goals that they set themselves are way too high and even if they do succeed perfectionism really just turns those successes
但你和其他人得出的一个非常奇怪的见解是，他们往往不注意“聪明地工作”。他们有时对所谓的“边际生产力递减”无动于衷。托马斯，这是什么意思？是的，这其实是完美主义文献中一个非常有趣的发现。我们知道完美主义者工作非常努力，他们把自己远远推出了舒适区，进入了一个“每付出一点努力，回报却在递减和下降”的区域。失败在完美主义者中非常普遍，因为他们为自己设定的目标实在太高了，即使他们真的成功了，完美主义也只会把这些成功
into dead ends because the better we do, the better we feel like we're expected to do. And so we just continually keep ourselves on tiptoes, clinging for more and more. I suppose it's like running on a treadmill that never slows down. So it's really tough, the success equation for perfections because they really never feel like they've ever made it. You and others have argued that perfectionists sometimes engage in what is called perfectionist self-preservation. What is this idea, Thomas? So this is the second reason I think why we don't see very strong correlations between perfectionism and performance.
变成死胡同，因为我们做得越好，我们就会觉得别人对我们的期望也越高。因此，我们只会不断地让自己踮起脚尖，渴望得到更多更多。我想这就像是在一台永远不会减速的跑步机上奔跑。所以，对完美主义者来说，成功的公式真的很艰难，因为他们真的觉得自己从来没有真正成功过。你和其他人曾辩称，完美主义者有时会从事所谓的“完美主义自我保护”。托马斯，这个观点是什么？所以这是我认为我们没有看到完美主义与绩效之间存在非常强的相关性的第二个原因。
When things start to go wrong, perfectionists do something really, really interesting. They withhold their effort in order to say face, to kind of preserve their image and their sense of self. And we've done a lot of experiments looking at this phenomenon. And one of the most illuminating those experiments is when a colleague of mine, Andrew Hill, took people into the lab, gave them a cycling task, and said, you've got to complete a certain distance in a certain amount of time. And based on your fitness, you should be able to do of time. And based on your fitness, you should be able to do X amount of distance. So he got them going with the task and everybody were really hard to meet the goal. And at the end, he told them
当事情开始出错时，完美主义者会做一件非常非常有趣的事情。他们会保留自己的努力，以此来挽回面子，保护自己的形象和自我意识。我们做过很多实验来研究这种现象。其中最具启发性的实验之一是，我的同事安德鲁·希尔（Andrew Hill）把人们带进实验室，给他们布置了一项骑自行车的任务，并说：“你必须在一定时间内完成一定的距离。根据你的体能，你应该能够完成一定距离。”于是他让他们开始任务，每个人都非常努力地去达成目标。最后他告诉他们，
no matter how hard they did that you failed. Now what's really interesting here is that after telling people they failed, he asked them to do it again. And that's where something remarkable happened because people who didn't have a great deal of perfectionism on that second attempt after the first failure didn't really change the amount of effort they put in if anything it went up slightly but the people who scored a high perfectionism did the exact opposite. They whiff held their effort on the second attempt because they're thinking in their mind as you can't fail at some of you, you didn't try. And if I put all of myself into this first effort and still didn't make it, well, I'm not going to do that again. Because the feelings of shame
无论他们多么努力，他们都失败了。现在这里非常有趣的是，在告诉人们他们失败了之后，他让他们再做一次。也就是在这里，发生了一件非凡的事情，因为那些在第一次失败后的第二次尝试中没有表现出大量完美主义倾向的人，并没有真正改变他们所投入的努力程度，如果说有什么变化的话，那就是稍微上升了一点，但那些完美主义得分很高的人却做了完全相反的事情。他们在第二次尝试中保留了他们的努力，因为他们心里想的是：如果你没有尝试，你就不会失败。如果我把全部精力都投入到第一次尝试中却仍然没有成功，好吧，我再也不会那样做了。因为羞耻
and embarrassment were so intense that I just don't want to feel those things again. And so this is, this is the perfectionism paradox, I suppose, this is that they really are so intensely fearful of that failure that when it looks like it's going to be a very likely outcome of anything that we're doing, then they take themselves away from those situations. That's incredibly self-sabotaging. It doesn't just look like complete withdrawal, by the way, it can also come in the form of procrastination, so we'll remove ourselves from doing activities that are really difficult in the moment because the anxiety is so intense. All of those things are not at all conducive to performance. So I guess that's why you would say you would not want to have a perfectionist who is the pilot
和尴尬的感觉是如此强烈，以至于我根本不想再次感受到那些东西。所以这就是完美主义的悖论，我想，这就是他们对失败怀有如此强烈的恐惧，以至于当失败看起来像是我们正在做的任何事情的一个极有可能的结果时，他们就会把自己从这些情境中抽离出来。这简直是极端的自我破坏。顺便说一句，这不仅仅表现为完全退缩，它还可以表现为拖延的形式，所以我们会让自己避开那些当下做起来非常困难的活动，因为焦虑实在是太强烈了。所有这些事情对绩效来说都是毫无助益的。所以我想这就是为什么你会说，你绝不会希望让一个完美主义者来担任你乘坐的飞机的飞行员，或者让一个完美主义者为你实施外科手术。你绝对不会想要像我这样的人来开你的飞机。因为如果发动机在35,000英尺的高空突然熄火，你需要的是一个能够非常清晰地思考操作程序的人。
of your playing or a surgeon carrying out an operation on you. There's no way you would want someone like me flying you play. Because if an engine suddenly craps out at 35,000 feet, you're going to need a somebody who's able to think very clearly about the procedures. There's going to be, by the way, no perfect way to get out of that situation. There's going to be many, many good enough ways to get out of that situation, there's going to be many, many good enough ways to get out of that situation. And what a perfectionist will do will search for the perfect outcome. Whereas somebody who is more conscientious, particular or diligent, they'll be able to
顺便说一句，摆脱这种困境绝不会只有一种完美的方法。有很多很多足够好的方法可以摆脱这种困境，有很多很多足够好的方法可以摆脱这种困境。而完美主义者会做的是去寻找完美的结局。相比之下，一个更具责任感、特别认真或勤奋的人，他们会知道
know that there are many different options that we can take. And the most important thing is to take the option that lands the plane safely. And that's the same with a surgeon. That's the same with working in a nuclear plant. Any of these very high risk activities, conscientiousness, diligence, really important qualities, but not perfection. So Thomas research has found that there's not just one kind of perfectionism, but really three.
我们可以采取许多不同的选择。最重要的是选择那个能让飞机安全降落的选择。外科医生也是如此。在核电站工作也是如此。所有这些高风险活动中，责任心、勤奋都是非常重要的品质，但完美不是。所以托马斯的研究发现，完美主义不仅有一种，实际上有三种。
And each type comes with its own particular kind of perfectionism, but really three, and each type comes with its own particular kind of psychological hardship. The first might be exemplified by something that happened a few years ago to a tennis player named Mikhail Yushiniy. At one point he was the number one player in Russia and a top 10 player in the world. During a match at the Miami Open in 2008, he missed a point and slammed his own face with his racket. After the third blow with blood streaming down his face, he required medical attention. Would he be
每种类型都有其特有的完美主义，但实际上有三种，每种类型都有其特有的心理痛苦。第一种可以由几年前发生在一个名叫米哈伊尔·尤日尼（Mikhail Youzhny）的网球运动员身上的事情来佐证。他曾一度是俄罗斯排名第一的球员，也是世界前十的球员。在2008年迈阿密公开赛的一场比赛中，他错失了一个得分点，并用球拍猛击自己的脸。在第三次击打后，鲜血顺着他的脸流下，他需要接受医疗救助。他会是
an example of what you would call a self-oriented perfectionist, people who subject themselves to incredibly harsh criticism? Yeah, absolutely. I saw that point actually, I remember it well, and it was at the end of a very long rally in which really the shot that was missed was one of the easier shots. And that intense emotion and outburst that came from a place of just complete self-loving for the fact that having made all of these really
你所说的“自我导向型完美主义者”的例子吗？也就是那些对自己施加极其严厉批评的人？是的，绝对是。我实际上看过那一分，我记忆犹新，那是在一个非常长的多拍对攻战的末尾，而真正失误的那一球其实是一个比较简单的球。那种强烈的情绪和爆发来自于一种彻底的自我厌恶，因为自己打出了所有那些非常
push-up, you couldn't make the easy one. And these are the intense expectations that self-oriented perfectionist people hold themselves to. And the moment they fall short of it, particularly in very important situations, the self-loving, the sense of how on earth could you have been so stupid, what on earth are you thinking, how could you have let yourself make that mistake, can be really so intense that in the extreme cases like this one, they can engage in some really quite aggressive self-castigation. And that's a signature of a self-oriented perfectionist. There is just a simply a lack of self-compassion and a strong sense of self-loving.
高难度的球，却连一个简单的球都没打进。这就是自我导向型完美主义者对自己抱有的强烈期望。而一旦他们达不到这些期望，特别是在非常重要的情境中，那种自我厌恶、那种“你怎么能这么蠢、你脑子里到底在想什么、你怎么能让自己犯这种错误”的感觉，在极端情况下（比如这个例子），真的会非常强烈，以至于他们会进行一些相当具有攻击性的自我谴责。而这就是自我导向型完美主义者的标志。其中仅仅缺乏自我同情，并伴随着强烈的自我厌恶感。
Some years ago, Thomas Amy Chua, a Yale law school professor, wrote a book called Battle Him of the Tiger Mother. And at one point in the book, she tells her older daughter that if her piano playing isn't perfect, she is going to take her stuffed animals and burn them. I want to play you a clip of a book interview with the author on PBS. If you read the back of your book, it explains how to be a tiger mother. There's a long list of things you didn't allow your children to do, your two girls. Let me read a couple of them. They were never allowed to attend a sleepover, have a play date, be in a school play, complain about not being in a school play, watch TV or play computer games, choose their own extracurricular
activities, get any grade less than an A, not be the number one student in every subject except Jim and drama, play any instrument other than the piano or violin, not play the piano or violin. When you hear that list read to you, does it sound extreme? Well, it sounds tongue-in-cheek to me, but it doesn't sound so extreme. When I talk to a lot of immigrants or immigrants' kids, they find it hysterical. They know that it's poking fun a little bit, but it really captures some truth. So, that is a remarkable interview.
I was really struck when the interviewer listed the number of things that Amy Chua kept her kids from doing. Now what I'm hearing is that Amy Chua feels that some of what she wrote was over the top. But I'm wondering Thomas, do you feel that this clip captures what you call other oriented perfectionism? Yeah, other inter-perfectionism is when we turn perfectionism outwards onto other people
and we expect them to be perfect and nothing but perfect and we'll certainly let them know. You'll know of or into perfectionist when you meet one. They tend to be quite brash. They will let you know when things haven't gone quite to plan. And it's what we call, I suppose, what Freud would cool projection, the sense that my intense desire to be perfect is projected outwards onto you too. You know Steve Jobs had a reputation for being like this.
People described him as, you know, berating other people for not living up to as high expectations. What's the line here between someone who has high expectations and as a demanding manager or a demanding boss, and somebody who is an other oriented perfectionist. The line is really the inability to accept at any time that things are good enough. Whereas someone that's demanding yes, once I've standard yes, is also somebody who can accept and appreciate when things are gone well, when there's been a success, and can give praise and appreciation for that, and anything else the difference.
A third type of perfectionism is known as socially prescribed perfectionism. Explain this idea to me Thomas. Socially prescribed perfectionism is the most extreme form of perfectionism, and it's a perfectionism that comes from outside, a sense that everybody and all around me expects me to be perfect, and they're watching and waiting to pass if I show any form of weakness. And carrying that around of you all the time isn't really tough. You need to be perfect all times. You need to make sure that your life is curated to show other people, you know, there are no weaknesses. And that is really tough to live under that microscope and to think that everybody in all times is watching. So you found that socially prescribed perfectionism might be rising fastest amongst all
the kinds of perfectionism in our society. Can you talk a little bit about what the data show and why this might be happening? Essentially what we're seeing today is a rise of about 40% in socially prescribed perfectionism from the late 1980s to the present day. That's a really, really big rise, which continues to increase. And it's most concerning because it's most strongly correlated with really quite negative mental health outcomes, like anxiety, depression, low mood, a sense of hopelessness and helplessness, things that are really quite significant when it comes to our mental health. And I think it's indicative perhaps of what have called a hidden epidemic of unrelenting expectations for perfection, which are kind
of taking over among young people. And why do you think this might be the case? Obviously, the one that most people point to is social media and the comparative lens that social media offers us 24-7 and without escape. But it's not just images of perfection in social media, it's unrelenting pressures to excel in schools and colleges, it's the modern workplace and the intense pressures to hustle and grind. It's changing parenting practices. They're responding to pressures in schools and colleges and the more competitive landscape to get into elite college by pushing young people in the realm of education. So there's all sorts of different pressures now that are weighing on young people and they're being internalised as pressures to be perfect.
When we come back, how to escape the perfectionist trap? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Thomas Karn is the author of the perfection trap, embracing the power of good enough. Thomas you call yourself a recovering perfectionist, and you've talked about the ways in which you're working to relinquish your perfectionism. And yet someone looking at you from the outside, you know, would see a prominent professor with a
job at a top school, someone who writes books and articles and gives talks that garner wide attention, someone might say, you know, clearly perfectionism worked for Thomas. It got him to where he is today. How would you respond to that? Well, clearly my perfectionism has pushed me forward in moments where I've needed it to. But the reason why I'm here is because I was very, very fortunate to come through at a time where people like me were supported to go to university, where I just so happened to meet the right professor at the right time, it took me to the right university, but without those remarkable moments of luck, I wouldn't be
here. The second thing to say is that I look, I guess, on the surface, like a very successful individual. And in many ways, I suppose I am. But I can't afford to live in the city that I work. I don't have a house. I've had to put off things like having a family and relationships. I've lived in countless different homes. I can't set root in communities
or build a long and lasting friendship group because my life has just been essentially one long period of flux. So yes it looks like success but it doesn't feel like success and when I look and reflect on this journey and how difficult it's been and the sacrifice I've had to make. I sometimes question whether I might have been better off. Back in my working class community with a job that gives me some sense of purpose, with a family and a house and a community, maybe I would be happier. Is it possible that for some people perfectionism might be something they say, yes, it's a curse,
yes, it's psychologically unhealthy, but yes, also, I'm glad I chose this life. I don't know if Steve Jobs was or was in a perfectionist, but if he was, you know, I suspect that if he was around, he would tell us, you know, I got to start a $3 trillion company. And yes, I drove myself and everyone around me nuts, but that's what I did. And it was worth it. Would that be okay for him to say it was worth it? Or do we get to diagnose him from the outside? No, I don't think we get to speak for Steve Jobs at all. If somebody carries perfectionism around with them and they're really successful,
and they, yes, they go through all of the things that I've experienced, and for them, that's worth it, and who am I to tell them that that is in the case? All I can say from what I understand about the work that I've done and my own experience is is that perfectionism carries a really heavy cost. And that actually there's plenty of evidence that we can be just as successful, if not more
successful, and not carrying around the emotional baggage that we carry around with perfectionism. One of the people who might fit that bill is the writer, Margaret Atwood. She's written nearly the equivalent of a book a year over six decades. When asked how she does it, she says, I'm not a perfectionist, that's one clue. So it's possible you can be very productive and get a lot of things done and not be a perfectionist. In fact, it might even be easier to get a lot of things done when you're not a perfectionist. And you'd be a little more happy to... I think Margaret Atwood is a great example of someone who can combine a desire, a joy,
a real sense of purpose and vocation in what she does, are you writing, and being able to do that in a way that doesn't carry with it this kind of constant self-worrying self doubt about it being perfect or exceptional. And really perfectionism is the fief of creativity in many ways. It stops us from putting things out there when they're not quite right because we worry about how that's going to be received. And I could tell you that first hand
from having written a book. You know, my editor, I think, was ready to throttle me at the end of the process because I was still tinkering into writing right to the end that it was so intensely difficult to get this one out. And outward has almost the opposite perspective. There seems to be a joy and an embrace of the process in her writing and that really comes through in her pages and it really comes through in herself analysis of how she writes and why she writes and the motivations behind it. So I think she's a really good example actually of how you can be incredibly successful, you can contribute so much to the world and not be a perfectionist. You know we're talking about perfectionism mostly in a work context in this conversation,
from having written a book. You know, my editor, I think, was ready to throttle me at the end of the process because I was still tinkering into writing right to the end that it was so intensely difficult to get this one out. And outward has almost the opposite perspective. There seems to be a joy and an embrace of the process in her writing and that really comes through in her pages and it really comes through in her self analysis of how she writes and why she writes and the motivations behind it. So I think she's a really good example actually of how you can be incredibly successful, you can contribute so much to the world and not be a perfectionist. You know we're talking about perfectionism mostly in a work context in this conversation,
and that is perhaps where perfectionism mostly manifests itself, but it can also show up in the domestic sphere. There's a phrase you like, the good enough mother. Tell me the story of Donald Winnecun. Donald Winnecun was an English pediatrician and he wrote extensively on parenting in the 1950s. And his idea of the good enough mother was something that was of a bombshell I suppose to mothers of the day who were holding themselves up to really impossible standards that were being placed on them in terms of the way they parent and the way they raise their children. And the idea of the good enough model wasn't simply that perfect mothering or perfect parenting is not possible, of course it's not possible, but it was also that it's not even desirable for the mother themselves, but also for the child. Because the child needs to learn about setback difficulties,
things not going quite to plan, and they need to know how to handle and deal with the frustrations and disappointments of those moments, because the world is gonna present those things to us all the time, and I think those were the key lessons that Winnicott really wanted to instill in mothers. The good enough mother can help to raise children while adjusted and happy and have a zest and purpose for life.
You see, there are steps that we can take as individuals to reduce the harmful effects of perfectionism. And one of the things that you've mentioned to me, Thomas, is that perfectionists tend to engage in a lot of rigid and unrealistic thinking. You know, they tell themselves, I must perform flawlessly and if I don't perform flawlessly, everything around me is going to fall apart. You have a writing technique that you use for yourself and that you recommend to others
that pushes back against this kind of thinking. What do you do? Yes, perfectionism, indeed, involves those really interesting patterns of thinking. What do you do? Yeah, so perfectionism indeed involves those really intruded patterns of thinking, I must do this, I have to do that. Why can't you be this? Why can't you do that? And I think the most important thing to do when those feelings are starting to make themselves known to you is to write them down, think about them, reflect on them, and ask yourself, maybe on a scale of one to ten,
how realistic is this, how achievable is this, and importantly, do I actually need to do this right now? What if I don't, what would happen? And again, often the consequences will be actually sit down, reflect, and not as catastrophic as your perfectionism would have you think that they might be. You know so often Thomas perfectionism is about seeing our work and our accomplishments as extensions of ourselves but of course we don't have to do this. Instead of making ourselves the focus we can make our work the focus. Now you had a role model close to home
who exemplified this idea of the work being its own reward. Tell me about your grandfather. My late grandfather was a master craftsman and I used to watch him for hours as he would fashion everyday things like banisters, chairs, window frames in his workshop. And they were immaculate. From the vantage point of a child, they just seemed magically, how on earth were you able to create these wonderful pieces of furniture? And of course, his meticulousness, his diligence,
his conscientiousness, his high standards were unquestionably the traits of somebody who worked really hard and wanted to do things well, but they weren't the traits of a perfectionist. And, you know, when I reflected on his way of striving versus mine, it became evident to me really that the big difference was that when he had created the things that he created in his workshop, he just took them to where they were going to live and left them there. He didn't loiter for validation, he didn't need that five-star review.
And as far as he was concerned, they just needed to exist way more than he needed to be loved or recognized or appreciated. And that is the thing about high standards, I think. They really don't have to come within security, only perfectionism graphs the two together. And that's why perfectionism isn't about perfecting things or tasks. It's about perfecting our imperfect selves and going through life trying to conceal every lash blemish and shortcoming from those around us.
So, whenever I'm back home, I visit the places where my grandfather's carpentry is still installed, because all those bannisters and stairs and window frames that he brought into the world, a really evidence of a man who had the vocation way bigger than himself. And of course none of those things bear his name, but they used and enjoyed by hundreds of people every single day. And I think just knowing that gave him an incredible sense of pride and accomplishment.
And that's a wonderful way to live and one in which hoping in myself that I can also find that. Thomas Karen is a psychologist at the London School of Economics. He's the author of the perfection trap, embracing the power of good enough. Thomas, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, have a minute. If you have follow-up questions about perfectionism for Thomas Karin that you would be willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please send a voice memo to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. Use the subject line, perfectionism. That address again is ideasathydenbrain.org. Please include your name and where you're from. 60 seconds is plenty. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Brigitte
McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Unsung Hero, we bring you a story from our sister show My Unsung Hero. It comes from Julia Minson. When Julia was in graduate school, her mother was diagnosed with advanced stage lung cancer. Julia dove into the research on the disease and discovered there was a new experimental drug that had a small chance of helping her mom. So she brought it up with her mother's physician, Dr. Charlotte Jacobs. She was skeptical, but Julia had done her research, so she pushed back.
You know, here I am. I'm like a 26-year-old grad student in psychology, arguing with one of the top oncologists in the world about a treatment plan. And she says, no, it's incredibly risky. She could bleed out. She could be paralyzed for what remains of her life. I could lose my license. I could go to prison.
Like, absolutely not. And so we go back and forth for a while. And she says, no, and I leave the office disappointed. And then we came back two weeks later for whatever the next appointment was. And she said, I took your idea to the tumor board. And I said, what's the tumor board? And she said, it's a gathering, we have once a month of all the top oncologists in Northern California, where each of us gets to present one case. And I discussed your idea, and they pretty much unanimously agreed that it was a non-starter for all the reasons that I already explained to you, but you know,
I really thought it was worth discussing and thoroughly thinking through and I'm sorry that we can't do it. And it turned out she was right, just weeks later, my mother passed away from the lung cancer, away from the lung cancer. And I still remember that conversation 17 years later, as the time where I felt most heard, perhaps in my life. And I have never seen her since when my mother passed away. And you know, never got to explain that my entire research program right now is about receptiveness to opposing views. And I think part of the reason that stories
particularly precious to me is because I spend a lot of time trying to convince people that making somebody feel heard doesn't require changing your mind. And to me that is like a very stark example where she did not change her mind, but I still felt heard. MUSIC Julia Mensen of Lexington, Massachusetts. She's a researcher at the Harvard Kennedy School of Government
and was recently a guest on our episode, Relationships 2.0, How to Keep Conflict from Spiraling. If you liked today's episode on perfectionism, please consider sharing it with one or two people in your life who could benefit from it. You know who they are. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.